okay welcome everyone
to this webinar and uh thank you for
joining today
today's topic is data science omics
logic data science so how is data
science different from
bioinformatics and what we typically
speak about is bioinformatics and
application into different types of data
or
to different domains biomedical data
today we are going to be talking about
the
more technical aspects of this upcoming
program
and how you can benefit from actually
gaining
a lot of the technical skills in
coding in statistical analysis and
machine learning
and really see the application of these
methods not just
at the conceptual level but actually
from learning about
why and how to pick specific methods all
the way to implementation
so i will be introducing the program but
together with me
dr harpietko or clinton and dr mohit
mazumder will be taking on different
sessions
and so before we begin i will just
briefly introduce omixlogic and what is
it that we typically do
so as i mentioned our focus is on
biology as a data science so we speak a
lot about the applications
of data analysis to high throughput data
and training that we provide to elevate
the level of biomedical research
and also enable research by providing
specific benefits and application to
oncology studies infectious diseases
neuroscience as well as agriculture and
so one of the connecting
dots between all of these are the
applications of data science methods
and so today we'll talk a little bit
more in depth on that topic
but typically we provide research
enablement through
analysis of big data so we actually have
big data analysis tools that are
designed to address
challenges in processing analysis
visualization and integration of
different types of omics data and
phenotypic data
we provide mentorship where you can
interact with our mentor community and
actually get
one-on-one private mentorship if you
need in
application to different types of data
and we also provide the synchronous
training resources so we have a
collection of
courses and programs organized with
collaborators
and different types of university high
school level as well as college level
training that we provide so let me go on
and briefly introduce this topic of data
science so what exactly is data science
data science
is the ability to work with data
so manipulate data organize data and
that is
informatics and then to apply
meaningful statistical analysis
techniques to this data
which include different types of machine
learning
and statistical analysis and even
visualization so it's really
analysis of that data and then finally
you have this
application of these methods and of this
data to a particular domain
or a specialization and when we speak
about data science in general data
science
tends to be agnostic so data science
methods just
knowing how to run analysis could be
applied to very many different domains
clinical business internet of things
finance and marketing biological
research
but specifically if we talk about
biological data
there's going to be a specific uh
additional
level of specialization that we need to
discuss and that will be
the way that data is generated and
therefore what are the specific
questions that are being asked of that
particular data set
and how can we later on interpret it
because as opposed to
other types of data a lot of times
biological data
is much more challenging to enter
to interpret and to understand
the technical versus the biological
patterns that we find in this data and
those are critical to distinguish
as we see to find interpretable
meaningful insights from this kind of
data
so the omics logic data science program
is designed to provide an overview of
statistical analysis and machine
learning methods
to discuss experimental design and some
of the technical variation that we need
to address before the data is analyzed
how to mine data for meaningful patterns
and what do we mean by associations
and then also the application of
complex biomedical or biological systems
using big data so how do we infer
these relationships from data and how do
we interpret them in the context of this
complexity of biological systems and so
specifically this program
is going to be focused on machine
learning for biomedical discovery
specifically we'll talk about what data
science and bioinformatics are designed
to do and how can you
learn the conceptual approaches but also
the practical skills
we will talk about data processing
cleaning and exploration
the application of data science and
biomedicine so what types of projects
and what types of examples are going to
be meaningful
for this kind of analysis and then we'll
introduce
machine learning algorithms for next
generation sequencing
we'll talk about data mining in the
context of
x omics integration or the integration
between different types of omics data
and how to apply deep learning
and clinical phenotype annotation for
some of the advanced methods of analysis
that
are being discussed and sometimes used
in the context of omix data
okay so i see that a couple of messages
here that people are mentioning that
they cannot hear
unfortunately i think that is probably
because of your connection or settings
so if you could try and rejoin
and so narika maybe you could post this
message also in chat if people cannot
hear
so specifically i think that in the
context of biomedical discovery right
we're talking about
the different aspects of biomedical
discovery where
machine learning and the analytics have
to be contextualized
because we are going to be trying to
connect the research
question or the clinical or biomedical
need and challenge
two different levels of statistical
analysis
and exploratory analysis that allow us
to connect this to the type of data that
is being generated
that essentially represents some kind of
a biological experiment
even though this experiment could also
be a design
of a data collection without a specific
experimental condition
but more in the real world sense and so
specifically in the real world sense
what types of data are we typically
talking about
so as we move into this era of precision
medicine we typically
mean that there's some kind of a
phenotype at the top of the iceberg
at the level where we can see and
observe the symptoms
and then underneath we have this
molecular data
that we need to connect to the clinical
data in order for us to be able to
integrate the signal and extract some
meaningful
results and so obviously in the context
of
biomedical discovery we're talking about
biomedical applications that include
treatment and selection of treatment
options stratifying risks for patients
but also we're talking about the
application for drug
discovery and for clinical trials
and so in drug discovery this analysis
of big data from
clint clinical data as well as from high
throughput experiments
can speed up the development and the
translation of discoveries to
the use by patients but also in clinical
trials it's an important component to be
able to
select the right kinds of patients to
define the right kind of strategy for
outcomes and also to translate other
findings that are beyond the objectives
of the specific clinical trials
in other words even if clinical trials
have failed to a
meaningful insight for the next round of
clinical trials or for modification
and so a big trend in both of these is
the discovery of
biomarkers and these of course are
markers of specific conditions
markers of specific biological processes
and we are looking for more and more
precise
markers oftentimes what that means is
that
we are not relying on a very clear-cut
signal
but a complex signal and that complex
signal is defined by the complexity of
omics data which could be of course of
many different types
and has many different ranges of
values that we can use to combine
into a signal signal and that signal
would be
a integrated signal essentially from
multiple types of ohmic data
so what kinds of omics data are we going
to talk about we're going to talk about
phenomics
which is the characterization and the
features coming from
image analysis from clinical data from
cell morphology
we're going to be talking about genomic
data or the mutations
or collections of mutations found in the
dna
we will be talking about epigenomics
signal where we'll discuss
chipset data whole genome by sulfide
sequencing data
transcriptomic data including
gene expression levels of gene
expression transcript expression
alternative splicing and we will talk
about specific
examples where we will use this data to
actually discuss the objective
and the type of data that could be
analyzed
because every type of data comes with a
specific set
of parameters that we need to consider
when we are trying to
set up and plan our analysis and of
course
one of the major challenges in this
whole field of onyx
is that the data is actually
unstructured right
so as you look at the
availability of data and the type of
data that is being
generated more and more this is going to
be
unstructured data because structured
data
requires processing so if you think
about collection of
biological samples from patients or even
generating that data
as a high throughput experiment you end
up with
unstructured raw reads you look at
different types of environmental
conditions
and because of that the first step that
we're going to be talking about
is processing that data or converting
that data from
raw to a structured format from
different types of biological material
that can generate
digital data to an actual organized
table that we can work with and so later
on i'll talk about some of the formats
that that data is stored in
so that we can discuss some of the more
technical
kind of structures for this data that we
will be looking at
but ultimately the objective of data
science
is to provide guidelines for different
steps
of data analysis which includes data
processing
as you can see right here exploratory
analysis
and the actual data analysis or
comparative data analysis or
sometimes modeling of that data and so
to go from
experiments to results those three steps
is what we will have to cover in this
program and talk about
data cleaning and processing formatting
it
for the specific type of analysis that
we would like to do exploring data using
visual methods and tools as well as
looking at different types of
approaches for data mining data analysis
where we consider different statistical
machine learning and deep learning
models and then
inference how do we actually test our
findings and
go back to where we started with so that
we can contextualize the findings and
actually
interpret meaningful results so what are
some of the
typical challenges in this process some
of the typical
challenges include analysis and
visual exploration of data where we can
use things like
principal component analysis or
clustering to really identify
some meaningful groups of objects based
on
all of the available data or based on an
extraction of data
oftentimes this also means looking at
taxonomic relationships where we can
combine
biological understanding of where the
data came from
with our ability to structure different
types of groups of data
in the patterns that we find so a lot of
the
processing specific to biological data
actually combines those two methods one
is just exploratory analysis on
aggregate of all the data that we have
including noise and signal filtering for
specific signal that is statistically
significant
or integration between taxonomy which is
a biological concept or a construct
and the actual analysis of similarity
based on the data availability that we
have
so because of that we are really looking
at
this collection of different types of
data
that also includes other types of data
and that could include
imaging clinical data chemical data
phenotypic data and all of this data
has to go through this process of
preparation
and organization of this data into
structured formats which
typically in the context of data science
is going to become some form of
a data frame and so the first thing that
we will do
in this program is we will discuss how
to
prepare different types of structured
data objects
data frames vectors matrices arrays and
lists
from the data sources that we prepare in
the processing pipelines
and then we will talk about how to
meaningfully organize
this information so that we can look at
relationships
between categorical data continuous data
and other types of data that we need to
organize
in a visual format so that we can
meaningfully spot
some results that are of interest for
our analysis
so sometimes this means just summarizing
the data that we have
sometimes it's looking at patterns
overall
a lot of times it leads us to the need
for data preparation
and data preparation means that
oftentimes data comes in a format
of different statistical properties that
we have to change
before we actually can run an analysis
designed to deal
with a certain data distribution for
example oftentimes when we look at next
generation sequencing data for
transcriptomics we need to first
transform it into a log normal scale
to have a more norm normal distribution
of course this is not a universally
applicable method because
when we come to data sets that are for
example metagenomic data
there there typically is not a need to
make that transformation but instead we
need to choose a completely different
method of analysis to extract
meaningful patterns now also when it
comes to
exploratory analysis we also need to
understand that
the majority of the data that we have
has
many different components and many
different sources of signal
that we could consider including
technical
including statistically significant
and including some non-statistically
significant but nevertheless
important for our ability to extract
meaningful portions of data
for downstream analysis and so that's
why we will also talk about
different methods of statistical
analysis including
t-tests f-tests anova
regression and other types of methods
that will
explain the relationship between
variables in our data
that we can ultimately use for
analysis and oftentimes we will find
that the statistical analysis has
limitations and the limitations come
from
several different types of sources so
one
is the variability in our data is
complex
and we cannot capture that complexity
using
standard statistical techniques because
of low p
values and kind of complexity of the
differences between noise and signal it
also can come
from just the types of data
because we might deal with many
different types with many different
variables that we cannot connect into a
single data set
and so that is really where we will turn
to the topic of data mining
and classification looking at many
different
types of methods that are typically used
for
analysis for classification
and for feature selection so we will
look at
different examples of methods like
decision trees
support vector machines hierarchical or
k-means clustering including clustering
for
big data sets like pam fuzzy and dbscan
we'll look at linear discriminatory
analysis and
other types of methods that will help us
use
this predictive analysis for
inference for feature selection and
something that we can ultimately
interpret
we will also dig deep into the
algorithmic properties of some of these
methods to really understand
how different approaches can help
extract
features that are responsible for
discrimination between different types
and different classes and so we'll talk
about
methods of feature selection including
support vector machines and random
forest for
feature significance as well as greedy
methods of analysis like stepwise
analysis of linear discriminatory
analysis
and such we will also talk about
an obvious topic that many are
interested in which is deep learning
applications in omix data so we will
talk a little bit about
different approaches for deep learning
uh how we can
discriminate between different types of
network topologies how we can optimize
some of the parameters
and ultimately what are the applications
where do these methods work well
and where these methods do not work well
and how do we
evaluate the performance and how can we
select the right type of method for the
right type of
project idea that we have now
importantly
many of these methods come with
ready-made packages
and with practical exercises that you
will be
able to run so we have prepared a
collection of
scripts and curated data sets where you
will be able to try
and run the specific analysis of your
choice understanding
the methods and their application in the
context of what's called a package a
package that might combine
many different specific scripts and
algorithms to extract some meaningful
insights that is considered to be a
standard
in a particular field as you can see
here this is the application of
non-metric dimensionality scaling in mds
for taxonomic analysis of microbiome
data so we'll discuss these methods
that really tend to combine multiple
methods of visualization
of processing of data analysis and then
translation translating that into
biologically interpretable results
now uh what we will do in terms of
your technical skills is we will
introduce
a number of different techniques and
technologies to
allow you to understand and appreciate
the implementation of these methods and
so for coding we will use
both r and python we will introduce you
to a number of different environments
where you can run this code including
integrated development environments like
rstudio
or visual studio for r and for python
respectively we will talk about sharing
your code
how do you effectively share your code
using jupyter
notebooks how to post your data on
github how to create
google colab notebooks that you can
share and run your code in those as well
but ultimately you will get a sense
or a landscape of these different
methods and tools
including some commonly used libraries
and packages like the base
in r or ggplot specific packages like gg
fortify and gpu br you will be able to
look pi to use python pandas numpy and
sk
learn packages including visualization
in matplotlib and seaborn and you will
be able to
apply general coding practices that are
going to be important
as you develop your skills in
bioinformatics and that includes
organizing your scripts using comments
and functions
setting up the development environment
dealing with
errors and troubleshooting your code so
learning how to
interpret the errors and finding the
reasons for the errors
and then how to prepare your data
summaries and submitting curated data
and metadata tables to sharing
repositories like on github or
dataverse and we'll use jupyter
notebooks on github and google collab
including we'll pre create some
interactive visualization using plot
links so
these are the topics that we plan to
cover from the technical side
but to really draw the connection
between
the technical and the conceptual we will
utilize
a number of projects and these are
curated projects that our team has gone
through
has annotated for the specific methods
that the authors
of peer-reviewed articles have used
and extracted some examples from these
data sets so that we can try and
practice on them
both learning about the usefulness of a
method
but also being able to understand why
this method is being used and how to
interpret the results or how to use the
results
from such a data science approach now
these different projects include many
different categories so many different
data types including
genomics epigenomics metagenomics
transcriptomics
many different types of projects like
projects and neuroscience
and cancer infectious diseases and
ultimately
this also will be applicable to a
project that you can
independently develop because once you
understand the data
and the needs to transform and
understand the data to
for analysis you can then actually apply
the same techniques
to a data set of your own now that data
set could be found on the public
repository
or it could be something that you
actually are already working on also
your own data set as well
okay so let me pause here and try to
address some of the questions so
if you have any questions please feel
free to post your questions
in the chat and i will go one by one and
address some of the questions
so the first question that i see here is
about
different programming that i have used
or that we will use in this program
so first of all we will go through i
will go through several examples in
today's session
of processing big data using the t-band
for platform
how to download from that portal
some r scripts that you can modify and
use
then i will introduce you to a number of
scripts in r
and in python so that you can see how
you can learn those as well
and then the other question that i see
here is can we publish our results in
journals using
secondary data so obviously yes you can
there are many
examples of re-analysis it's called
meta-analysis or re-analysis of existing
publicly available data sets
typically about 95 of the actual
data is not being published it's only
the five percent of the most significant
exciting or relevant findings that
people tend to put in the journal
article
but that means that 95 of that data is
still available for
re-analysis and oftentimes you can
actually take and combine multiple data
sets
integrate them into a new data set and
ask a completely different question
or even perform the similar analysis
using different methods
and that oftentimes will lead to novel
insights
might mean to something it might mean
that you can find
something that you know could have some
significance and and if you do
then you can actually share that in a
journal
article of course we do not commit to
helping you go
through the submission we just can help
you by training
and offering you guidance in how to
develop a bioinformatics project
okay so hadiya is also asking if the
course will be recorded
yes i will come to that in a second this
session is being recorded it's also
being live
streamed on youtube so you can always
find it on our youtube channel
but i will talk a little bit about the
sessions that we will cut
we will cover in the full program and so
those yes will be recorded and shared
with all the participants
are there basic courses for a biologist
who doesn't have computational skills
such as arm python from
lingaraju so yes i think that
we live in an era of data science and so
it's critical
for anyone who has an interest in
applying data analysis to large data
sets to
learn gradually some of the required
data science skills
including coding and so that's why this
program
i think will be also useful for those of
you that do not have
the skills to to code already but want
to acquire those skills
so that's really what the program is
about i think it's also going to be
useful for those of you that do know
some coding
but would like to learn a little bit
more about machine learning deep
learning
and how to visualize and explore your
data and so i think to
explain how the program can achieve all
of that in a short time
i would like to demonstrate to you how
the program will run
and what are the different components of
knowing how to ask a question being able
to access
big data sets and integrate them and
then how to apply some of these data
science skills
to also explore and use machine learning
on those data and and then demonstrate
your results share your results with
others
okay so if there are no other questions
thank you durba also for your interest
i think there are many applications in
agricultural sciences as well
we do have another session that's going
to be coming up about agriculture and
the application
in agriculture but today let's continue
and talk about this
general field of data science and see
how we will achieve all of this
during this upcoming program so the
upcoming program
will combine three different things that
you will be able to do and
the first one is interactive sessions
just like today
you will be able to join a session on
zoom and one of our mentors myself
uh clinton or harpreet will be guiding
these different sessions that you can
interact with us and with others
ask questions get help with some
technical challenges
that are being um that you're getting
stuck with
and then also to get the assignments and
the review
for your completed assignment so that
will be covered in the interactive
sessions
included will be some self-guided study
materials so these self-study
materials that we offer is something
that i will show in just a few minutes
and then we will also use some tools and
these tools include
the t-biome for platform many of you are
already familiar with that it's a
logical and user-friendly way to analyze
all kinds of omics data including
genomics transcriptomics epigenomics and
metagenomics
and then we will turn to our coding
portal
where you will be able to try different
scripts including scripts that you've
used on the platform i'll demonstrate
that in a few minutes
so that you can understand not only how
this platform works but also
what is the specific code and how to
modify that code
and practice so that you can test
whether you understood or not so
i will demonstrate that in a second so
i